despite it being hit with some backlash
after he performed it on the nbc near z
show blake shelton has officially
released his new song
minimum wage today some people thought
it was insensitive
to people who are really struggling
right now financially
blake was on the bobby bone show this
morning and said while he did take a
moment to reflect on the backlash
he doesn't put much weight into it
well i've learned over the years not to
just roll my eyes you know until i
really get to the bottom of
whatever the particular controversy is
that time
but when i saw what this one was it i
mean i don't want to dismiss
everything but it kind of was a roll of
the eyes because
i think if there's if you can find
something offensive
about this song i mean you're either
you're just
looking for a fight or you're probably
not a country music fan to begin with
you know
it's i really can't uh
draw a connection between anything
controversial and a love song
but you know it's uh it's the times
we're in i guess but
uh we're just we're proud of the song
and uh
we love it what was the first job you
had where you made minimum wage
i roofed houses in ada oklahoma
and uh it may have been more than
minimum wage i think about i think i got
paid eight dollars an hour
uh and i feel like way back then minimum
wage might have been like
six dollars an hour or something closer
to that so
man i stepped right into the big money
roofing houses
so carrie just commented she probably
didn't see that clip yet so she says
blake shell never had a minimum wage job
or is he or has his entitlement
protecting him from such a fate
no like blake shelton started off very
grassroots i mean yeah you started a
roofing job like this is not a guy who
was born with a silver spoon in any kind
of way i mean we talked about the song
already
there's been a lot of songs about you
know that subject matter of
love don't cost a thing but i do think
using the phrase minimum wage is a
little bit it's a triggering
thing for people right now right yeah
absolutely i think it's just the timing
right now i agree with you it's totally
a triggering word
um and because he is so rich people are
like what what do you know about minimum
wage and all that
um and he kind of gave an explanation he
still was making more than minimum wage
i don't think he ever actually
worked at minimum wage i mean it's a two
dollar difference but um
no i i think that he's seeing things
from one perspective because he
is in love and this is a love song and
this is a new single
what else is he gonna say he's totally
not gonna be like i get what people
have to i understand what they're
feeling i apologize no because then
you're not gonna get that song played
out the radio
if you agree that it's offensive it's
better just to kind of ignore it so that
you can
keep continuing to promote this song
um but i feel like you know blake has
always shown himself to be
charming and sweet and grounded and
humble i've always seen
i've always thought that about him just
from what i've seen of him i don't know
what he's like in real life but
he's always kind of had that persona
it's a love song it is country music you
know they
a lot of singers say things in country
music that i'm like i know you're not
really doing that there's no way
you're gonna slash the tires of that car
you're worth too much money sis
like there's lots of things you know
that happen um or when they talk about
you know their pickup trucks and all
these things and then
you know i see where they live and they
don't have a pickup truck in sight
they live in a mansion they don't even
they don't even got a country like
they're in beverly hills you know like
there's things like that but
it is what it is it's a song i would
more so if i was blake it would just
bother me that anybody
felt bad listening to my song it would
be more me acknowledging that
because you never want to make people
feel bad i never do so
i would i would have hoped he would have
kind of acknowledged that but
it is what it is there are bigger things
in the world
folks right nikki says i don't take
issue with this song i think people's
sensitivities are just extremely high
that's true during this time everyone is
mentally financially okay yeah i think a
lot of people are on edge
right now so something's gonna really
set them off especially on uh social
media just poor timing she says
britney says i think it would have been
better received at the beginning of his
career
that's an interesting point or someone
yeah that didn't have this
basically yeah he's engaged to gwen
stefani now
uh deborah says the song is fine all
he's saying is that you love me for me
people are crazy
bugging blake of this and i don't like
country music um
aaron is not offended at the song he
needs to read the room better though
yeah and it's funny that you said about
i do find sometimes with country artists
that they
present this lifestyle or they appeal to
a certain you know
part of their fan base when they don't
live that life at all like i remember a
couple years ago i was at um
a country music festival and
interviewing all these guys about you
know the routine the tour life
and they like some of these guys are
telling me the amount of drinking that
they do
and they have six packs so it's like
there is
what you're telling me that is there's
no way that's your lifestyle if that was
your actual lifestyle you would have a
big beer guy like they're living on a
tour bus
and they'll have six packs it was like
what you're telling me that you
like to say oh like after i said i'd
drink three beers every night and then
go to bed it's like
there's no way so it's like i think
there's a little bit element that they
present themselves in a certain way to
appeal to a certain part of their
audience when
yeah that's not what really is happening
behind the scenes but i guess all pop
stars oh
you just made your stars do that to a
certain extent right
yeah like i think when you're a
songwriter you're gonna write about
present
and you know for sure you're gonna write
about past i understand a lot of like
hip-hop stars for
example uh maybe grew up in the hood and
they
that's what they remember so they rap
about that a lot even though they've
totally changed their lives around and
they're in a completely different place
different circle different environment
but that's still a huge part of their
lives so they talk about it um
but yeah i feel you there's playing on
certain things and what's real and
what's fake
i mean show business it is show business
honey these are all show girls
show ponies job